hey guys we have each played around
three hours of watchdogs Legion it's a
super interesting entry in watchdogs
particularly because of their play as
any one mechanic which seemed like it
wasn't that work actually kind of works
pretty well so we'll jump right in what
did you guys think of the fact that
every single NPC in the world can be
recruited to dedsec and played I just
use one of those things you hear about
you like how is that even really
possible then you get in and then you
literally just go to anyone on the
street and the recruit button is right
there and sometimes you can do it
instantly sometimes you need to do it
there a mission to like actually get
them in but it's just one of those
things that you just it's one of those I
guess next gen feeling things where it's
like okay this is what we can do now the
technology is so advanced that literally
anyone can just be your main play coyote
in this game they have most of them have
unique abilities that are suited to
their they're like charisma so for
example we had a construction worker to
choose from there was someone I
recruited off the street who was really
into hacking so the hacking ability was
actually sped up and I could hack
different objects in the world more
efficiently with that character so there
is a dynamic of almost not necessarily
class-based system but it almost it
plays like that and the fact that these
things are randomly generated and from
what we played so far are pretty like
well put together like there's no we
didn't really see anything that was
broken about it is it's pretty
impressive to see it in practice yeah I
recruited someone who I didn't wasn't
able to recruit instantly so I kicked
off we played a little bit of the
prologue then we were throwing I think
around ten or fifteen hours into the
game we were told where you could
recruit a ton of people instantly and it
feels like this it's just like these
people have schedules they have lives
they have relationships with other
people in London and sometimes you
needed to explore those relationships in
I think the it was the cold a like a
deep investigation yeah Alex I like
Shenmue like every character in Shenmue
in like the tiny village or saying we
had a
at a time in place that they would be
every day and when you pick someone off
the street you can just keep them in
your log basically and you can come back
to them later and it'll tell you oh you
know at 11 o'clock they go to work and
they'll be at this place so then you go
to that place at that time and you can
also just hit a button and wait for them
that they will be somewhere as part of
their life and it's it makes it feel
like like a real world you know it's yes
kind of wild yeah there's there's
definitely an element that feels organic
about it even though these things are
procedurally generated another
interesting thing is that there are a
lot of characters or NPCs on the street
who who aren't fans of dedsec like they
are actually opposed to dedsec and so
you have to go through a bit of an extra
step in order to recruit them such as
like the Albion Police Force that roams
the streets you can actually flip them
over but you have to do something for
them so that's when that scheduling
thing comes into place and the profiling
mechanics really come to surface is
because you have to kind of understand
oh there's an extra layer that I need to
take care of if I really want them on my
team so yeah that's that's also an
interesting thing and like some of the
missions or at least a mission that we
played had you do exactly that yeah I
found it interesting cuz I was
immediately suspicious of whether the
system was going to work so I picked
someone up at the very start of the game
to go through the main we were give him
like four or five main missions we had
access to and some side content so I
went through a multi pot recruitment
quest process it was only like a couple
of different quests it was he had
missing person case a friend of his had
gone missing and it's someone you had to
go retrieve and save from like a little
Albion stronghold it wasn't overly
difficult but it added a few extra steps
and the fact that these things are
procedurally generated on this lady is
like hard to get your head around but
then I used him for the rest of my three
hour playthrough pretty much and the way
he seamlessly fit into every
conversation like he had unique things
to say like I I mean you have to wonder
how they have written so many different
voice lines and how many different boys
act
they got for all these different
characters but I got on a bike at one
point and he's like oh my mom would kill
me if she knew I was riding this bike
you saw me riding me he just felt like
such a complete person which is also
something that I find now horrifying in
combat and running around the world in a
GTA style because running people down
when they have a lives personality is in
relationships yeah terrifying so the
game will actually point out recruits
that have extraordinary abilities that
might help you especially so like want
us could be a hitman and they have like
real guns but if you accidentally run
over one of those people the the AI in
your head will feel like oh man that guy
could've been really usable you just
killed that guy so never mind let's move
on
obviously we only play this a few hours
that I'm really curious to see how this
tracks over like a 60 80 hour period
because I feel like we you will run into
a few anomalies so what are my first
characters that I had was like a
middle-aged like Asian grandma kind of
person who was a UFC fighter for some
reason which is a completely implausible
situation to begin with that sort of
even though she only looked about 40 or
50 she had the grandma voice that the
grandmother saw in the trailers so she
sounded way too old oh how dreadful but
I think they're I think what really
shines is that their unique traits are
important for gameplay perspective so
though one of the missions actually took
place in a construction zone and the
main character I was playing as was a
construction worker so I waltz right in
without anyone turning like to me and
with any suspicion unless I got too
close for some reason but I was able to
walk around this this this danger
dangerous zone without any problem of
course once I got to a hostage then I
freed them and then I was able to walk
right out after that and it was I saw
how important it is to have a variety of
characters so like the recruitment
system like I got attached to that one
character I want to play it with him
throughout the the rest of the game that
would have been cool but I think it's
important to when you play this game to
have an assortment of roles because you
never know when the situation may come
that you need a certain ability or if
you need a certain way to present the
certain characters to get through a
mission in a certain way yeah yeah
definitely some of my hacker characters
had crazy abilities that let them sort
of like steal keys from just like any
distance because usually that's a
proximity-based
attempt and while like every character
can do some basic hacking and has basic
sort of stun weapons like obviously some
folks will exceed in certain abilities
being able to recruit anybody just still
it instills the sense of like community
and trying to get everyone on board like
you know in a social way with the
campaign of dedsec and what they're
trying to do not that we got that full
story being that we only played a few
hours but it seems to be able to achieve
it in a way that you know no other game
has a system where this works but that's
a possible thing even if it isn't like
perfectly seamless so I think you played
a little bit more of this story than we
did Michael what's the general setup
that you got the sense of and how'd you
find it the setup is that London is
falling and there have been terrorist
bomb attacks throughout London and
dedsec has been trying to get to the
root of it but what ends up happening is
that London is thrown into a police
state a surveillance state and then a
private military corporation comes in to
be the law enforcers which I think I
personally have concerns about as it
fits into watchdogs legions themes but
there is essentially four ringleaders
what have you supposed to be the evil
ones that you're supposed to take down
we only saw two of them so far so one is
the evil bad guy who runs Albion which
is the the private military corporation
and you see a lot of images of police
brutality on the streets as carried out
by the Albion officers that roam the
streets and then there's a there's
another character she is kind of the
head of a crime syndicate of a vast
criminal underground throughout London
yeah I found it was really weird going
around London because I think the game
looks gorgeous even it's in its current
state of like what we had access to and
I think yet is streamed filled and we
were able to go in but I think they was
still running and less quality than they
have upon proper release but it's
strange when I'm like buzzing through it
all the future vehicles by the way oh my
gosh night and day to driving a car at
the start of watchdogs one which
straight out made me stop playing that
game but speaking of which there is a
plenty of different ways to play
watchdogs legion and what one of the
things I really enjoyed was how much
leeway you seemed to get like I would
have most of my missions go to hell and
I did not have clever ways of getting in
I'm not a hacker extraordinaire so I'd
end up just getting in massive
firefights but I found that getting away
from combat situations and also just
taking out a ton of offices non-lethal
it's a completely viable way of going
about things and didn't destroy my
playthrough at all but how did you guys
approach missions be hackers or combat
or I kind of did a mix of both I had a
hacker character because I one of the
big things I liked about the watchdog's
series in the past is being able to
complete a mission you know just sitting
outside on a park bench basically and
you can do that with you a little spider
bot that can remotely trigger like
physical like circuit breakers and
computers and stuff as well as hopping
from security cameras to security camera
and downloading data that way
and obviously with the hacker character
you have more more powerful abilities to
do that and I also did a bunch of
stealth using my hitman and using like
gun food takedowns and what I kind of
start so it's it's fun to do both which
is good and I feel like what are the
joys if this game is gonna be going into
a mission with the wrong character and
like seeing all the ways that you can
work your way out of it one of the
conversations about watchdogs - was how
a lot of situations devolved into lethal
gunfights
I feel like Ubisoft has taken that into
account for watchdogs Legion because
there are a lot of less than lethal
options in this game so you can have a
pistol a submachine gun and even a
shotgun that are all shooting like taser
rounds so you don't have to actually
kill anyone I don't want to be the one
to enact the violence because that is
what we're trying to fight against
of course some situations in a game may
call for that but I was pretty I was
pretty impressed with the way that the
less-than-lethal Gunz warped because you
know ordinary citizens are not gonna be
cool with just like shooting fools in
the heads right it kind of checks out
and speaking of always being on the
backfoot I noticed that some of the
characters in the game actually have
negative perks so for example some of
the really good characters that might
have a very powerful ability might also
have a negative ability that says when
this guy dies this guy a girl dies they
die for good like usually when one of
your characters goes down they get
hospitalized or they get arrested and
you know that you have to wait for a
cool down before you can start using
them again you can also recruit like
people like paramedics and judges to
help them get out faster they're really
old people caught hottest mobile so you
can't like Crouch Clint Hawking who's
the creative director for Legion worked
on Far Cry 2 which was like infamously a
game that always had you on the back
foot and always through negative [ __ ] at
you like getting malaria and just like
your gun jamming and just that puts you
in like edge-of-your-seat like really
tense situations all the time I can see
that kind of existing here as well
especially in a time of like social
media and people sharing like funky
stuff that happens in their games I feel
like this is gonna be a good candidate
for those kinds of movements with
watchdogs - I really liked Marcus
Holloway as a character and I think that
that that game told a story that was
specifically for him through his eyes
through his interactions with dedsec so
I think you're gonna lose an element of
that with watchdogs Legion you're not
gonna get character specific narrative
and I think it's and I hope that
watchdogs lesion like makes up for that
with how it tackles its themes but I'm
not I mean I'll get attached to a
certain character probably because it's
one of those things like like those
perma death situations where like oh and
XCOM oh my favorite rifle man died and
now I can't use them anymore I think
that'll play to that but in terms of
like building characters that will have
to happen to the characters you don't
control
yeah so yeah I'm a little bit concerned
about that but we'll see well great
thank you guys so much for sharing your
thoughts and do check back to site where
we have plenty of things on watchdogs
Legion and everything else that we found
out from the ubisoft forward stream so
stay tuned to gain spot and we will see
you next time
you